what's up fellow Geeks today we have the
xiaomi 13 Ultra which is xiaomi's newest
flagship phone we'll be putting it
through the gauntlet of Kenshin impact
pubg mobile Cod mobile and honkai star
rail to see if this phone can perform
Under Pressure performance wise for the
xiaomi 13 Ultra that we are using has a
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 a adreno 740 for its
GPU 16 gigs of RAM 512 gigs of storage
and everything plays out on a 120hz ltpo
AMOLED 6.73 inch screen with a 5 000
million power battery before we run the
test let's do a baseline of the
temperatures on the front and the back
which of the back first you get a little
trusty temperature gun here and let's
check the back and you know it's sitting
very nicely at 25.2 degrees and around
the camera here as well 24 that's much
cooler here because it's glass but I had
to say that it is a very nice leathery
texture at the back I mean it basically
just is leather in the back here so yeah
the camera module is huge but other than
that I think this would be great to help
out with the grip of the phone this my
game the wheel leader on but we'll find
out so the front let's check it out
and 25.8 in the front and 26.3 27.6 all
right things are looking pretty much
okay so let's get into our first game
Hong Kai stereo okay before we start
playing honkai Star real we want to test
out performance so let's use game turbo
mode and I have set everything to the
highest quality performance mode down
here let's see for Call of Duty this
will go up this is a Snapdragon adrenal
screen down here and everything set on
high quality to ensure that we are
pushing the phone to its limits and
let's see honkai stereo
all right so now that we're here
oh actually I have to say the speakers
are pretty good on this thing
yeah I'll put oh a little frame starting
there already another way in the hub
just a little bit but yeah let's just
check out our graphic settings real
quick
and here we go we're on 30 let's reset
the 60 put everything on very high I
believe yes very high 60 FPS 60 FPS all
right and then everything else is on
high NPA listings on ta okay that's fine
and yeah let's just restart the game and
come back so I have restarted the game
and we are playing this with everything
turned on on performance mode and
so far it's actually okay compared to
what I just saw before I restarted the
phone it was starting a little bit but
let's just check out how it looks like
and this screen is
really doing it for me actually it looks
really good look at the textures on his
polishing right there yeah it's making
you look really fancy the character
models look really good so let's just
jump to herta's office okay so now that
we heard the surface we'll be playing
some simulated universe and over here
let's just attack
start laying down the hood so yeah it
starts a little bit as you can see just
a little bit and it's just whack
all right nothing much
[Music]
so that's great
look at this
and then in the Airy
very nice two down one down sorry
okay so ultimate and everything it's
with an ultimate let's see how that
plays out
okay nice
actually I think pretty well with
performance mode
all right see that so yeah all the
effects and all of the animations are
working out pretty well let's just go
with seals animation real quick
oh nice so so far no frames start doing
nothing gameplay is smooth and even with
the ultimates that we've used only just
one so far it's shaping out to be pretty
solid so far and also I think it's a bit
dark for you all so I'm gonna increase
the brightness real quick just a little
bit all right okay I think this is a
little bit too so let's continue I don't
think you guys will have much of an
issue when it comes to combat with
honkai stereo
but it's looking pretty good but let's
um okay I'm not gonna waste any of the
on this
let's use an audio on the next encounter
all right weakness again
you're gonna be steamrolling through all
these enemies let's do this
[Music]
little bug here but
still looks cool oh yeah look at those
numbers
beautiful
nice
[Music]
all right nice this little eerie
oh
goddamn here that's GG before we fight
the elite I think that the xiaomi 30
ultimate is doing pretty well we've been
through a couple battles by now so let's
actually just check the temperatures
real quick let me just get a little gun
out we are at
36.8 degrees in the front
34.7 ish so it's actually doing pretty
all right 37ish here
say okay all right let's check the back
of this leather back here it is heating
up a little bit on the sides
so let's check the leather bag 28.35
let's check the camera module that is
also on the 35.8 it's not too bad
but the sides here
oh it's the same story all right it's
not too bad okay yeah so this is
actually handling heat pretty well but
you know we haven't tried gentian yet so
yeah honka is good enough actually for
me but I know a couple of you want to
see how Genji would run like when it
comes to this so let's just keep going
okay let's just hit him with an ulti
there we go explanations
beautiful
I didn't do much
all right let's get it in it's time
Target threat index
board
all right here you go
let's go
nice damage reduction
oh okay she's gonna oh my God she's
gonna die
okay let's hit you
okay
she's down it's not fun
man oh my God that pig Christ
like this
time for radiant speeds well that's not
good
that's not good at all
okay so I think this might be the first
time I get a I have a squat wipe oh I I
think I can actually make it
okay it's all wrong never mind we're
done
okay so with that we're going to be
hitting this run of funky Style real
this is bad this is my first time ever
getting a squad wipe so let's just do a
final temperature check yeah 38.6 in the
front
not too bad actually because honestly it
doesn't feel that warm and let's check
the back with this leather back here
it's a bit warm right now
and 36.4 handling it pretty well on the
camera module we're looking at 36.8 and
on the sides about the same so yeah what
I think about Hong Kai stereo and this
thing so far I mean besides the terrible
team selection and everything
it's actually doing pretty well on the
performance mode again we were at 100
now we're down to 94 and that's after
like 20 minutes of play so we are
actually doing pretty all right with the
xiaomi 13 Ultra so far and with this you
know there was very minimal starting
here in there I'm in between scenes sure
but it's not too bad it's doing pretty
much okay Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and the
adreno 740l holding up pretty well with
the performance mode mind you so let's
move on to the next game Kenshin impact
okay so we are out of the heels of
honkai stereo let's actually check out
the temperatures on the phone before we
hop into gentian and 36.8 37 it has gone
down pretty quick so far I mean it was
like 38 in a bit before this I literally
just started recording again let's check
the back there's a 36.4 35.6 right now
that's not too bad 36 on here on the
camera module and we are doing A-Okay
actually so
let's just play the engine impact and so
as soon as you can get out the screen
right all right so with that let's just
pick engine impact all right so now with
the ring genjin uh let's check settings
real quick as we do
and Graphics okay so on high and
everything 60fps everything is turned on
so looking good
I believe I hope so so that's the little
oh yeah oh gosh okay you see that
you spin the camera a bit too much it
lags all a bit yeah that's man all right
that looks check that look out before we
get to Inazuma and yeah it's looking
really good and spiffy handsome man and
yeah models are great let's do a quick
change to ayaka
all right a little bit of frame starting
in there but she's looking great as well
okay let's head over to Inazuma okay so
another Inazuma you know
it's looking pretty good but compared to
honkai style this is yeah okay but to be
fair it's an open world and to be fair
in Hong Kai style real we didn't really
go about walking pretty much everywhere
and also the open world isn't as fast as
Genji impact so things to take note off
and yeah but it looks it's a really good
looking game on this phone I really love
the screen again the camera module is
getting in the way a little bit but with
that I think we should be fine oh okay I
think with that we should be fine let's
actually just go back to that look and
let's start running through let's start
frolicking through nizuma
oh as you can see oh yep okay so it's
not handling pretty well the thing just
rendered in if you saw it oh they just
went it in as well
classy
all right so as you can see it's not
performing as expected even with
performance on high quality through the
adreno slash Snapdragon app window that
we saw in the game center but yeah huh
it's a bit spotty okay so now that I see
the situation a little bit with this
phone let's do a bit of exploring the
open world and maybe some combat so now
that we hear this looks really pretty on
the ltp0 AMOLED screen oh my gosh look
at that and again the speakers are
really doing it for me so let's just do
a side question real quick I believe
it's right below us
and trying to get down here prepare
notable defense and then let's throw
them right on top
nice
all right let's play some defense let's
just all do this real quick
nice okay so
okay I've seen worse before I've seen
phones handle this a lot worse than this
so far than the xiaomi 13 Ultra so far
it's doing okay
I think
all right let's change it up
doing pretty all right so far
all right
[Music]
okay and yeah that's it so for some
reason okay in a confined area like this
the xiaomi 13 Pro actually handles it
pretty well okay so with combat and
exploration so far it's actually looking
pretty much okay just that you know the
frame start doing the lag is very sporty
it's in like the best so just keep that
in mind but while we are here I would
say that the draw distance again is
looking pretty good and the speakers on
the phone app is really great and while
I was in the combat scenario just now
the camera module on the back does get
in the way and it makes it a bit
uncomfortable to play over a long
periods of time so just keep that in
mind and with that let's move on to the
spiral Abyss so notes before we start uh
confined area
a large number of mobs more than usual
so just keep that in mind
vaporize all them
should be doing fine yeah
yeah come on
all right so far doing okay I mean it's
actually the gameplay is pretty smooth
so far in the spiral Abyss so come on
there we go
the response times and everything on the
phone okay I mean everything's
registering as I intend them to register
so
everything's gonna be okay I'll see you
real quick
very nice let's move on let's switch up
and use another ulti
[Music]
real quick
it's supposed to Bubble quick and yeah
that's done I didn't do any temperature
checks Midway because you know honestly
I've not really felt much of a
difference for when I was playing honkai
stereo it's still quite comfortable to
hold in hand nothing is like burning up
or anything so thermal Management on
this thing seems to be pretty alright
but let's just confirm that by checking
it with our temperature gun
and 37 wow
that's sexually winning than Hong Kai
impact wow okay
stereo wow okay this is okay these are
some of the lowest numbers I've seen for
genshin let's check the leather back
35 wow okay camera module 35.9
okay
that's interesting okay so it's handling
here pretty well on performance mode
with everything turned on high
so ah
that is interesting
okay okay xiaomi okay so with that let's
move on to Call of Duty mobile before we
get into the next game this channel is
supported by Brands who help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for this sponsored message meet
the Cyber 15 gaming laptop from MSI
check out this translucent material
design that not only looks good but
feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7 HC use processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and they
immerse with its nahimic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com okay so we're hot off
Genji impact let's check for
temperatures real quick
and you're at 32 ish all right this is
cooling down pretty fast all right 32
32. this is doing pretty all right in
the back
camera module
32 and 33 yeah it's looking pretty
alright so far it's cooled down quite a
bit in a short span of time and also
just one thing about the camera module I
think this will give me a bit of a
headache once we start this test so with
that let's move on to Call of Duty
mobile once I can get out of the screen
again okay touching and touch
sensitivity and everything isn't the
best on this phone I think yep as you
can see I'm trying my best I'm trying my
best it's over here this thing right
here is like way too high you can see
but it's this is way too high
look at that
okay if I just you know let me just do
this there we go all right so with that
let's play some Call of Duty mobile so
now that we've entered Call of Duty
mobile that means it looks really good
especially all these lighting effects
look at how the light bounces off her
hair and of a skin suit on here so it's
looking really good oh look at the shine
on my EK and it looks really good okay
so with that let's check out settings
real quick
all right all in graphics and we're set
to very high for graphic quality frame
rates on Max and
multiplayer everything is turned on so
with that let's just get into a game of
Call of Duty okay so so far everything's
looking pretty good my sides look
amazing so let's see how it plays out
again the camera module is getting in
the way of things
so it is a bit uncomfortable to play
with right now it's a bit awkward
actually
oh
come on
Christ okay
oh boy
oh man okay this is bad okay hello
oh my God that was bad okay you know
what
can we do SMG let's just go with
something safe like my EK over here but
also you know you've got to keep in mind
that I am playing this through the
monitor on my camera so it is a bit
difficult
but other than that you know okay
very nice
both of my layouts a bit wonky but never
mind
oh yeah
[Applause]
oh man come on yeah
so man okay so this camera module is
getting in the way of my gameplay
that I'll say it's quite a bit
distraction so unless you get a case
especially for FPS players you know
because timing and reactions and
everything is are basically everything
we need that's a brilliant battle and
how comfortable we are about holding the
console is very important as well
this is not are you doing it for me
there really isn't much to say in terms
of ergonomics so
yeah I mean this isn't a gaming phone
like many I have reviewed so far
so yeah you gotta cut some slack
[Applause]
there we go all right that is a comeback
if I've ever saw one very nice okay so
my thoughts so far on this film when it
comes to FPS is a case so you know major
player man you gotta
ah it's this thing this thing right here
will get in your way it's a beautiful
camera I'm pretty sure it takes amazing
pictures as well but man it look at this
it gets in the way when you're doing
this I mean like sure you can kind of
justify it as a grip of Swords but
unless you get a case that accentuates
this thing this thing will get in the
way of your game playing and if you're
playing for a long periods of time or
even like a pubg later which I know for
a fact I'll be feeling that in a bit it
will get on my nose it really will get
in my nose you know if you want to play
any other game You'll Play like Candy
Crush or something it's fine this is
great for that but other than that man
you might want to think twice if you
want to get this phone for gaming I feel
just especially if you're an FPS gamer
for mobile gaming because this thing
will get in the way I mean a case solves
everything right but if you can't find a
case that matches up with the way you
play that will be an issue for you so
that's one thing that I foresee and I've
been complaining about the last few
minutes okay so with that let's check
out their pictures real quick
and here we go 35
34. 33 yards doing pretty well and the
back 34-ish yeah
is a pretty well compared to obviously
Genji and honkai but it's like doing a
lot better than Hong Kai that's for sure
so yeah this is actually shaping out to
be pretty all right this thing is
amazing so far performance with games
like pubg you know performance with
games I call it utr doing pretty well so
far yeah performance with performance
with a game like Call of Duty mobile is
doing pretty well so far I mean it's
still it's no Hong Kong impact it's not
against it's no Hong Kai style real it's
no Genji impact but it is handling these
games pretty well so with this
let's move on to our final game pubg
mobile okay so before we get into pubg
Mobile proper let's check temperatures
real quick we are just off Call of Duty
mobile and 32 33
doing okay I believe it's all right
all right and the back
we are at 32
32.5 and the camera watch is about 20
32.3 so it's doing pretty all right it's
just that this thing will get in the way
again but we'll see how it feels like
when we play a match so let's do that
okay so now that we're in pubg let's
check settings real quick
and graphics and audio we're at 90 FPS
graphic smooth because that's what you
guys want 2018 and everything is set so
let's jump into a game
all right so now that we are in the
lobby things are looking pretty alright
so far the Sun is hitting off a leather
jacket very nicely Shadows are working
pretty much fine and yeah 90 FPS is a
whole experience at least the option is
there now so before we get into the
match I have to say the camera module
will get in the way and the speakers are
on the sides here and here and you will
tend to cover them while you're playing
so you know have some Bluetooth
earphones or earphones and try not to
get irritated by the camera module again
this isn't a gaming phone it's a camera
phone it's a camera camera phone to be
exact so let's just see where we land
and so far everything is looking pretty
good we're in a distance the C130 is
looking pretty great and 90 FPS we're
looking to have a lot of fun
and where is everyone dropping right now
I have no idea am I a major master I am
a master great
so far we are doing a okay we are moving
down I'm going the wrong direction 90
FPS looks crazy on this thing as you can
see I mean you guys can see 60 FPS on
the screen but other it's looking to be
pretty much fine so let's go hit the
shooting range I have no idea what
everyone else is at
yes
and let's just hit all the way down
and stop picking up mood
and we are all okay cool we're here nice
all right let's just pick up everything
you pick up I mean there should be some
rifles by the range over there so let's
just keep moving
but so far it's looking pretty good I
mean at any FPS and smooth graphics and
everything this is turning out to be
pretty much fine
I mean we are playing with a Snapdragon
8 Gen 2 and adrenal 740 it's doing
pretty much okay for a game like Pub G
other games maybe not so much but pubg
runs very smooth with this so let's just
keep looting around and finding for
Stuff
hopefully I can get a 556 rifle
somewhere
300 rounds of ammunition that should be
enough
oh lots of firing
where are you at
okay
behind
all right you don't
right so gunfight gunfight gun fight
against
okay there's a guy
I did it
okay and they're all down nice
no you stay away
the camera module does get in the way a
little bit if not a lot I don't know how
the rest of you would take it but just
letting you know it's there another
Squad behind what
let's get a new helmet
oh nice city
where you at
somewhere here
okay they're fine with us I'm not sure
where they are
oh they are
nice
okay doing pretty okay so far
doing pretty well actually oh I just got
the honey badger I really want that so
so far even with those two gun fights I
believe the phone handles it pretty well
you have enough space to move your hands
around I mean that's like 6.73 inches of
screen down here for you to navigate
hands around I have huge hands so this
helps out a lot
all right let's just keep running
towards the marker real quick
all right so into the circle we go but
before that
35 34 36 oh that's that's a lot hiding
Call of Duty or about the same if I
remember right but we are doing Aoki
right here
let's check the back real quick
okay and the camera module is about 35
the green difference and the sides
aren't doing too hard to be honest oh
foreign
oh boy that was bad but yeah um
right now oh boy
can you get in front of me
somewhere
oh this area is hot right now
let's heal up real quick man all I want
to do was just test temperatures that
we've got like what three squads on us
that's something oh
[Applause]
okay
push up
pushing up and I think he would fit off
this guy stay right here
he's down
you shoot some people up there
it's fine from here
foreign
but honestly you look pretty much okay
lots of fighting lots of fighting
happening how many have I killed so far
I think I've killed seven people
but yes let's just do our temperature
checks while we can well there's still
peace so
uh 36 oh it has risen up a bit I mean
we've been in an intense gunfight and
36 is on the front
and the back
35 35 34 and because it's only like 35
here I'm guessing it's like 36 here 35
close to 36 on the camera module so yeah
it's actually doing pretty all right
it's heat it's already heating up a lot
per se so we're doing pretty much okay
on this front and I'd say in this
playthrough pubg so far like you know
this game runs hella smooth but it's
just the camera module gets in the way
the speakers on the side you're covering
everything up and those are my main
grabs with this phone but other than
that it works fine it plays fine it
plays great on some games so with that
let's just move on to our final thoughts
the xiaomi 13 Ultra works well but only
with certain games Hawkeye style at 30
FPS showed some cracks at the start
before we switched over to 60 FPS before
it started to perform relatively smooth
with a couple of hiccups between
transitioning from the open world to
battle modes the other ones from each
character played are extremely well and
beautifully on its display however
gentian impact was where it really
started the struggle with basic camera
movement doing drastic frame rate drops
and stuttering in an area with a bigger
population of NPCs you can see them
rendering in however it plays very well
in a confined area like the spiral Abyss
games like Call of Duty and pubg mobile
have no issues at all and play out
extremely smooth but the phone is a bit
of a letdown thanks to its camera module
at the back make it sometimes awkward
and uncomfortable when placing your
hands around the phone and also covering
up the speakers on the sides so if you
want positional Intel such as footstep
directions you're gonna need to use
wireless earbuds or headphones however
the speakers are fantastic to listen to
and thermal Management on this phone is
surprisingly good if not better than a
lot of gaming oriented phones that price
their cooling systems lastly touch
registration isn't at its best but I
think an update will be able to
calibrate that all in all the xiaomi 13
Ultra works great for certain games but
you're gonna need to get used to having
this camera module at the back in the
way of your grip which I think can be
remedied by having a phone casing to
level out the back of the phone that's
it for this video follow us on all of
our socials shown at the bar right here
to keep up with all the stuff we have
and if you like what you're watching
maybe hit the Subscribe and like buttons
it goes a long way in helping out the
channel if you want to see more stuff
check this out
[Music]
foreign